more than a week after police discovered
Cash Out founder Bob Lee bleeding from
multiple stab wounds on a San Francisco
sidewalk investigators now have a
suspect in custody
[Music]
Nema momentum a tech consultant was
picked up by police at his home Thursday
morning he's facing one charge of murder
we can confirm that Mr Lee and Mr momini
knew each other A source told CBS there
is video that shows the two men leaving
a building together and it's believed
that Lee was in a BMW driven by momenti
prior to the stabbing an industry leader
in Mobile payment services at the time
of his death Lee was the chief product
officer of the cryptocurrency firm
mobile coin momenti owned a cyber
security company called expand I.T Lee's
violent death spurred prominent Tech
leaders to take to social media to
criticize San Francisco leaders approach
to crime